looking for the last talk for today and
probably the one holding you back
between you know from drinks so the
title of my talk is so you want to be a
CEO and before I even get started with
the talk I thought I'll give you a bit
of free introduction tip and I want to
talk about this concept of this thing
called the Peter Principle even heard of
the Peter Principle all right a few
people Peter Principle is all about this
is about from a book that was written
over 50 years ago and you know it's
called Peter Principle because the the
the name of the author was his last name
was Peter so what he says in this book
is that in a hierarchical organization
every competent employee raises up the
chain to a level where they are no
longer competent or they become
incompetent so you take the example of a
software developer you know you sign up
you know you you employ a person who's a
software developer and this person is
really good at what he or she does very
very competent developer and you know
the manager looks at this guy and said
well that this guy's got potential I'm
going to promote this guy and so this
person moves up to become a senior
developer and and then maybe lead
developer or tech leader one of those
things right and this person is really
good it's a badge looks at you know this
guy's got really good potential I'm
gonna promote this guy and make this
person now a dev manager right and so
what happens is like you know the reason
that this person you the person actually
got this promotion was he was he or he
was evaluated on the skills that not on
the skills that are needed for the new
job but on the skills that were you know
for the from the previous job so this
new job requires things like people
management and working with you know
having one-on-one conversations with
immediate reports and working on their
personal development and things like
that but what this person really likes
to do is they try to gravitate towards
the things that they really enjoy and
are good at which is hey I would like to
do some code review I would like to cut
some code although that's probably not
as what is required in the job and so
this person actually becomes incompetent
right now what's worse is this thing
called the Dunning crew
perfect I'm sure a few people have heard
about this one as well right so after
this is the dunning-kruger effect is
basically a cognitive bias where people
completely overestimate their own
competence so this is the thing where
there are completely incompetent people
and they think oh man I'm really good at
this thing right and you add these two
things together being incompetent and
the dunning-kruger effect it's a little
deadly combination so so how do you get
out of this thing so you can't get out
this thing and there's the the stages of
competence itself the first thing is you
you get a promotion in your you're
incompetent and you have no idea that
you're incompetent this is the stage off
lay or you're in unconscious
incompetence and hopefully you get to
the stage where at some point in time
you actually recognize the fact that you
are actually incompetent you basically
the kinds of fact that hey man I suck at
this job I need to do something about it
this is the stage where you kind of like
become like you're still incompetent but
at least you're conscious about it right
you can do something about it
this third stage is you're competent but
you're consciously competent so you know
you've gone through some training and
you you know you follow some playbooks
or certain scripts and things like that
and you're you're you know competent
you're starting to get competent but you
got to make a lot of effort to be
competent in what you're actually doing
and or a period of time hopefully you
get good at this and you become
unconsciously competent so you don't
have to think about it you don't have to
look at some you know playbook or
something like that and how you do your
job you are basically just competent
right and that's what you need to get it
unconsciously competent but then the
whole cycle starts again because your
manager sees potential in you and then
such promoting you right anyway so what
does this got to do with this talk well
you know you want you're here in this
conference or I'm guessing that you're
either a developer or you know an
architect or you know your ticky
effectively right so you're probably
really good at cutting code and
architecting things and so on those are
really good skills to have but when you
move up the chain and you want to become
a chief technology officer or CTO some
of those skills are gonna be useful but
there's a whole bunch of new skills that
you need to do
and hopefully one of the things that I
would I'll be talking about a bunch of
things that I have actually learned from
my own experience in in you know skills
that you need to develop I'll talk about
them and hopefully it'll be helpful for
you so it's not that after listening to
this talk you're going on Monday and you
got all the skills initially to become a
CTO but it'll actually set you hopefully
in the right direction all right so
let's he give a bit of instruction
my name is my education I started my
career as a developer and I've had
several leadership roles in in
technology including that of a CTO and I
currently work for an energy company in
Melbourne it's called AGL energy
probably a lot of people know about it
because we are we sell energy across
Australia my twitter handle is my
education you can tweet about it and
that'll boost my vanity a little bit and
or you can actually send me an email
with questions write mail if my stock
mah C dot SH and I'm I'll be more than
happy to reply to your email so what is
a what is the CTO I mean of course the
CTO stands for chief technology officer
some people call it chief technical
officer it's pretty much the same thing
and if you look at the job description
for a CTO from let's come out and you go
to seek calm and look at the job
description no to CTO job descriptions
are the same every organization has its
own definition of a CTO and then you
start to look at the size of the company
and what they do if you're looking at a
small startup company then there are
different things that they look in this
video if you're looking at a large
enterprise then a CTO they're looking
for something something completely
different but what kind of done is I've
kind of like distilled all these things
together and I've identified four key
characteristics that a CTO really needs
I call these four bubbles right and I'll
talk about them one by one the first one
is delivery experience so what people
expect from a CTO is that you should
have at some point in your career
successfully delivered projects or
products or programs of work so they're
hoping that you are capable of
delivering things the second thing of
course is they're expecting you to be
really good technically I mean this
the tea in you know the technologies
that's that's what the tea in sitio
stands for right so they expect you to
know how technology works how it can be
applied and so on they also expect
management and leadership experience
once you're a CTO you've got a seat at
the table the exact table and you need
to have good management experience and
you should have let people in the past
to you know to be part of that that that
group of execs and last but not the
least people also expect you to have
strategic thinking
so not just focusing on things that
you're doing today or what the product
does so you're the company does thinking
about hey now what are you gonna do in
the future and effectively you know I
can summarize the the job of a character
of a CTO you know these these four
bubbles put together now depending on
the size of the organization itself the
size of these bubbles vary you know if
you're in a start-up they're probably
gonna expect it you are really good you
know if they want your strong technical
knowledge bubble to be a lot bigger than
some of them because that's what they're
looking for
whereas you go into a large enterprise
organization some of the CEOs there are
technical knowledge is a lot smaller and
but they do have really good management
and leadership experience and they're
probably really good at strategic
thinking and that's what the company is
looking for so you know these four
bubbles is what I'm gonna be talking
about today now the another question
that actually get asked quite frequently
is like you know where does the CEO sit
in when you have a whole bunch of other
bubble or other roles in other cxo roles
you know where is the CIO and you have
roles like the chief digital officer is
popping up and chief design officer and
so on and so forth so what does it all
mean now again there is no right or
wrong answer every company has their own
interpretation of what a CIO is and what
a CTO is but McKenzie did a study and
they looked at the industry itself and
one of the things that they actually
noticed is that the chief technology
officer has a law is more external
facing and they focus a lot on the
products itself right very sincere
another hand is very internal facing so
you
if you have you have your ERP systems
and you know CRM systems and things like
that
to support your staff a CIO is probably
more suited to that and a lot of
organizations the CIO is more you know
there are people who come from a
financial background we end up becoming
a CIO so they have very little technical
knowledge but you know it varies from
company to company as well and of course
you have a whole bunch of other roles in
Australia with a lot of head off
technology roles and we also have VP of
engineering that's more like a you know
outside of so there's a lot of VP
positions right you have director of
Technology and VP of Technology and VP
of engineering and so on and so forth so
it really doesn't matter what the title
of the of the job is and you know you'll
you'll find that a lot of things that
I'm going to be talking about it's going
to be relevant in all of these roles
itself right so any leadership role in
technology the things that I'm going to
be talking about is hopefully relevant
alright so let's get start jumping into
each and every one of those bubbles
right the characteristics that I
actually spoke about first and foremost
let me talk about the delivery
experience itself like I said earlier
when you get to this level people are
gonna expect you to have successfully
delivered a product or project or
multiple projects and you know programs
of work or whatever that may be
hopefully on time as well right so for
this there are three critical skills
that you need to pick up three areas of
knowledge that you need to to pick up
and an experience that you need to have
and put them in those three buckets
people process and technology and tools
tools and technology so start looking at
people first people is all about
managing people so when you get to this
role they're gonna expect you to to have
people leadership skills and you know as
as the organization gets bigger and
bigger typically what happens is you may
have lead group of individual
contributors but as you move up the
hierarchy right you will start leading
people who are already people leaders as
well and sometimes the kind of the way
that you manage these people will be
be different to the way that you
actually manage individual contributors
as well like so so that that you know
the dynamics of that changes so anyway
talking about leadership skills itself
there is this this this thing called the
Blake and Morton's leadership grid and
that this grid helps you place where
your leadership style literally sits in
if you if you if you can like start to
map this thing in a in a graph where you
start putting all the concern on welfare
of the staff on and the y-axis and then
you start to put the concern for getting
things done on the x-axis right you can
actually start to look at the country
club management style which is
effectively like you're this kind of
person that you know you really don't
care about getting things done but
you're really focused on the welfare of
the employee you want to make sure that
person is like you know really looked
after and you know there is a certain
school of thoughts that they said that
say that hey you know this is actually
quite good you know if you basically
focus on the welfare of the employee the
employee you know getting things done
will actually get it you know that'll
take care of itself it doesn't quite
work that way and generally when you had
some you know big mergers and
acquisitions and things like there are
people are going through a really hard
time this kind of leadership style
actually works but in the long run it
doesn't so you the other one of course
is there you know you don't care about
the consider but the welfare of the
staff and you don't care about getting
things done which is like the
impoverished management this is the
thing where you're kind of like a
dysfunctional leader and you know you
probably need to get out of that you
know you're probably not a good leader
and either you need to change companies
or you know go somewhere where you're
not looking after leading people itself
middle-of-the-road is like you know it's
like neither here nor there and that's
not seen as a good way good place to be
either right there are some people who
look at tasks compliance and they see
this as like you know these are the
people who think that they really care
about getting things done no matter what
it is right there focuses on getting
things done they don't care about the
welfare of the of the employee itself
and there are several leaders who
actually you know follow that and what
they do is they they use this
transactional leadership style where
what they do is they say hey you know
what if you get this thing done I'm
gonna reward you with a really good
bonus at the end of the year or there's
some some you know a promotion or
whatever it is that's you know and it's
very transactional get this thing done
you do this for me I'll do this for you
and the same hand they basically say
well if you don't get this done guess
what's gonna happen right there's the
threats that are in place now I had a
manager ones who actually came up to me
and said Mahesh I just had a chat with
the CIOs going back several years now so
I just had a chat with the CIO and I've
promised her that we're gonna deliver
this project in three months time and if
you don't deliver this in three months
time your job is on the line
I'll see okay we haven't even started
this done and you haven't consulted me
on how long it's going to get how long
it's gonna take to complete this project
and if we don't you know not consulting
me at all but you've gone to CIO and you
said that if we don't get this done my
job is on the line
and he paused for a second and then he
said yeah okay cool so anyway so the
short of this is like I did deliver this
thing in the time but then I quit after
that and he said oh you know what my I
was just saying that to motivate you oh
my god I don't think I need this kind of
motivation right anyways the
transactional leadership also doesn't
work in the long run it may actually
work in some cases for some people what
you really want to do is is this team
you know that the team management style
of leadership right where your concern
for staff is actually quite high and
your concern for getting things is
actually quite high and for that a lot
of people these days talk about the
seventh leadership model sound
leadership is all about this leadership
philosophy where the leader exists to
serve the people rather than the other
way around
and there's this a really good pictorial
pictograph whatever you call them info
info graph that all riley have actually
put out that
talks about the command-and-control kind
of model where's the sales leadership
model right some leadership is all about
actually you know trusting your people
to do the right things and developing
them and you know putting them first in
a lot of these things and one of the
things I'll actually talk about so in
leadership is that just because you're
following a servant leadership doesn't
mean that you completely say hey you
know guys I'm you know I'm gonna
delegate this thing I fully trust you
and walk away from it right and set them
up for failure so the one way of
actually doing this is this this model
called situational leadership where in
situational leadership again you know
you'll see this two-by-two matrix in my
talk pretty much like every alternate
slide has this thing where I plot
something in a 2x2 matrix and in this
case you have I got the level of support
needed for the staff on on one axis and
then the level of direction near and the
other axis right so there are some
people who you know who don't need much
of a moral support they don't need a lot
of encouragement they'll actually get
things done and the task is also easy to
manage they've got a complete handle on
it
they require very little direction so in
that case delegation actually works
really well so you provide things like
deadlines and you keep a close watch on
it but you literally let the person go
ahead and finish the task in some cases
they don't need a level of direction but
they need a lot of emotional support you
know you gotta go hey you know I'm
really quite confident that you like to
get the job done and you know you know
there's a lot of personal support that
you actually give and that's that's kind
of like the supporting model that you
want to follow and in some cases you
know they you know you provide direction
and so so that the graph basically says
it shows what you need to do this is say
you do a lot of coaching and trying to
get them to try try and help them now
it's called situational leadership for a
reason
so depending on the kind of situation on
the type of person you probably need to
decide what kind of
support that they actually need and the
same person may need a different kind of
support at different periods of time as
well so just because you know this
person is really good at one task
doesn't mean they're really good at
another task so this kind of leadership
style actually works quite quite well
now that we looked at people I want to
start talking a little bit about process
itself the dictionary definition for
processes it's a series of actions or
steps taken in order to achieve a
particular end now our end is a
successful delivery of a product or
project or whatever that may be and one
of the things that are actually noticed
the right is that in the past when we've
had really successful projects they have
had these really smart people in them
you know basically the heroes of the
project they'll literally carry the
entire team forward and if you go look
at what these people have done is there
are certain practices that actually
follow well you know they may be you
know for the improving the quality of
code they may have done things like
introduced things like TDD or you know
just unit testing for that matter or
they would have had introduced things
like you know building the really good
you know the build pipeline or for
communication they may have done
stand-ups and things like that all now
what we've done is we've looked at all
these things and because you don't have
heroes in every project we've kind of
like paksy step and so there's a process
you know we call it scrum hey you gotta
use scrum because it's highly successful
and so on and so forth right so that's
what process in a way it's all about in
a way it's a repeatable thing that has
been successful in the past and we're
hoping that we'll actually be successful
in the future as well so for a lot of
devs and out there you know who are part
of a team one of the advice that I
actually give to them is if you haven't
been responsible delivery of things you
know you've not been a scrum master or
anything I always tell them hey put your
hand up and take up the drawl and
because that's a really essential skill
to have on how you hope you deliver
things and being a scrum master can
actually help you with some of those
things or you know if you're using
things like scaled agile framework you
know
we you know the our tes as they call
them you know put your hand up to pick
up one of those rolls you can gain some
really valuable experience
another thing talk about is this concept
of a DevOps culture and typically in
large organizations what happens is
people do you know there are developers
who actually develop stuff and literally
they check it across the wall to a team
that actually deploys it and there are
people operational people who maintain
these things so when things do go wrong
you know there are so far away from
what's actually happening and you know
it really you know it's only only
affects a certain group of people drops
people who actually look after it so a
lot of you a lot of people basically
think oh you know we're gonna set up
DevOps as a team and what they end up
doing is the DevOps team ethically just
builds the you know CIC D pipeline
that's probably what they do and they do
deployment but that's not what it is
the DevOps culture is is the thing where
it's kind of like I'm you know it's the
merger of dev and ops and you know for
for a company like HDL which is like a
big F effort to basically tell people
hey you know if you broke it you kind of
like fix it and be prepared to get a
call in the middle of the night if if so
be it right and so it starts to people
start to think about in what are the
things that they need to do from
monitoring the application you know how
when things do go wrong how can I
actually find out how things have gone
wrong and it changes the way people
think about how they write code as well
so and the last one is around good
engineering practices you know we talk
about this is like basic hygiene in a
way things like writing unit tests and
your CI CD build pipelines how you do
monitoring and logging and how do you
make your application really resilient
and self-healing gaining all these
things are going to help that they're
all process oriented things that are
going to really help you in the role the
last one is about the tooling itself
right and I've got a I've got a whole
bunch of tools on the right of the
screen I'm not saying these are the
tools that you need to know about but
what I wanted you to understand
is that there are various tools that
your your team will end up using right
you'd be using things like for there are
testes and there are developers and
their architects and whole bunch of ops
people out there they all use various
tools and you need to have a good aware
enough where nasaw what are the things
that they're actually using for things
like collaboration and how the measure
metrics and things like that that's
gonna hold you in good stead in the long
run sorry I'll try and make it a bit
more buzz would or you know thought was
docker in there or kubernetes was boxing
in there blazer was missing I think
sorry that's not like it's not some of
these aren't tools per se anyway the
second bubble is the strong technical
expertise a CTO is generally expected to
be like you know the chief architect for
the organization itself and when things
do go wrong you know from a security
perspective for example and they want to
have they want to throw to choke the
CTOs throat is the one that they want to
choke right so you are kind of like
responsible for everything that goes on
in the organization generally you know
like this group of people are you know
fairly technical in nature and you know
you probably fit in well in this thing
you know from a technical point of view
you're probably well covered you know
this is one skill that you probably have
but there are certain things that I want
to call out the first and foremost is
that you may no longer be committing
code so if you're a developer and you
know if I tell you hey you know you're
not going to be writing code anymore you
know you may say well you know I
really passionate about this thing and
they say well I know the startup of like
10 people and you know the CTO there is
cutting code yes you know some companies
the CTO does cut code and when these
companies start to scale up at that
point in time you as a CTO are probably
more valuable than other parts of the
business doing other things than sitting
and cutting code so if you're really
passionate about cutting code and you
don't want to let go of this thing maybe
this role is it for you right so the
other thing is around the breadth of
knowledge being more important than the
depth of knowledge itself and again you
know they're always exception to the
rule people say you know hey blockchain
I you know if you're doing something in
blockchain and I read you know the
person the CTO needs to have a really
deep understanding of blockchain
technologies like really complex
whatever it may be
yeah okay you know sure you know you
know IOT devices and things like that
maybe you need to have like a bit of a
hardware bent and so on but in a way ret
of knowledge is more important than the
depth of one specific area so if you are
UX developer now and you say you know
I'm really happy cutting code in angular
and react and so on and so forth and I
don't want to look at anything else
think again and you know I hate the you
know the concept of you know full stack
developer because I in my opinion
everybody needs to be a full stack
developer so start to think about
getting into other areas it's staying
technically relevant now this is gonna
be a challenge right so now here's the
thing you're now CTO and you're no
longer cutting code well at least code
that goes into production and so how do
you take how do you say technically
relevant right and there's all these new
technologies that are coming out right
and so how do you find out how these
things are going to be you know what is
the thing that's gonna useful for your
organization and so on so it is a
challenge so some people have a natural
ability to pick things up going to
conferences actually helped and
networking with your peers and trying to
find what are the latest and greatest is
you know you know you need to keep up
breasts off those things you know taught
works does a TechRadar right that's a
really good way of looking at it you
know I mean not necessarily agree with
the things that they put on it you can
develop your own TechRadar right and
then see based on the company's needs
and so on what are the technologies that
are relevant for you and the last thing
over here is embracing the business
needs right so in a way in a lot of
company area you know we you may you may
use how to use blocks and again as an
example
so you can say well I've got blocks and
I'm trying to find you know a problem to
fit in with this thing I mean that's not
the way you want to go about it right so
as a chief technology officer in at
least in a product company you will have
a strong say in the direction of the
product itself and so you want to make
sure that it actually meets a business
need and not not the other way around
where you've got a technology and you're
saying well I can use this technology to
you know come up with a problem that I
can actually solve the third bubble is
around the management and leadership
experience itself yes yeah and that's a
thing that was actually talking about
right so I'll give the example of the
taught works
TechRadar right so that may be relevant
for certain people I think what you need
to do is to work out what is gonna
really work for you
right just being buzzword compliant
isn't good enough I mean like you got to
figure out what's gonna work for you
this is why you know that the last thing
that I actually spoke about is embracing
the business needs it's really important
that you make sure that that is actually
met so the third bubble of course is the
management and leadership experience
I've kind of like broken this into into
into three buckets right one is what I
call as operating functions the other
one is operating models and the
operating rhythm itself I'll start to
look at each and every one of those
things and that the more you as you move
up the the management hierarchy there
are certain things that you need to
learn to do finance is probably one of
them you know if you've got a team to
run someone is probably giving you a
budget and say hey you know here's some
some money I want you to run the team so
you need to start thinking about things
like OPEX and capex and
[Music]
and how you actually manage them and you
know suddenly something something
happens right so there's a big program
of work that's actually come up and
someone you know the board is approved
like 10 million dollars to you know for
the next year
and so how do you actually spend that
money you know of course you know you've
got like ten million dollars of capex
that money's gonna disappear at the end
of the year so if you start to hire a
whole bunch of full-time people what are
you gonna do at the end of it are you
gonna let them go is that is that your
strategy maybe that's not a good way of
doing it right what if you actually
hired contingent workers you contractors
and consultants and so on and so forth
and you hire them up and at the end of
the period they all go and along with
them the the IP and the knowledge that
you've actually built up is actually
gone as well so how do you balance these
things out right those are things that
you need to learn so and what happens
when the ten million dollars runs out
and you still need to maintain the
maintain the code at the end of the
period right so you go up to your boss
and say well you know yes you know I'm
happy to take the ten million dollar cap
X and do stuff but I also need some
optics from the next year in the
following years to have a team that'll
actually start to maintain some of these
things and again you know you probably
need to to work through and figure out
the combination of full-time employees
and contingent workers that you actually
hire because you know that'll be some
churn but in the film people who leave
and so on at the end of that period you
may you want to make sure that the the
knowledge still stays in the company
right so when I talk about Finance it's
only you can actually see there's a lot
more complexity involved in it it's just
not about managing the budget there are
you know and you know little nuances
right I mean one time one of my bosses
actually gave me a tip and he said if
you give in a budget and if you come on
to the bunch let's say you're gonna make
a budget of two million dollars and
you've come under it and you've done it
for like 1.5 million dollars right and
you're like wow you know like I've saved
the company like half a million dollars
is awesome and then you go next year and
then you ask for another two million
dollars go you ask then you know you
manage to do it in 1.5 million dollars
you've got budget is being cut this time
right so he said that that is a real
problem in the in the corporate world so
make sure that you don't come under
right if you come under just like a
little bit or he said like even better
always go or buy a little bit right so
anyway
there are other things right you may
want to contribute you will find
yourself working a lot with with people
in culture or HR people you want to make
sure that you attract the right people
you want to make sure your company or
organization is a destination for talent
and you need to figure out as a CTO
you'll be involved more and more in
making sure how that function works you
want to you know do you have plans on
getting interns and train them up so a
lot of those things you need to work
through there other areas that you will
contribute as well you know things like
sales and marketing and you know
technology will play a role and a lot of
those things I've got M&A over there as
well mergers and acquisitions and I say
that a lot of these companies start to
you know as company sometimes grow these
days they acquire they they grow through
mergers and acquisitions and so on so if
you ever get an opportunity if you know
bosses you know you're gonna buy this
company and I would like to do some due
diligence on these people now I would
say put your hand out right get some
experience in these things because it's
gonna help you in the long run and yes
you not be cutting code for the next
couple of months or whatever it is or
next month
but these are some of those experience
that will that'll be quite used quite
useful in the long run the next thing I
want to talk about is the operating
rhythm as well now one thing that I
failed to mention earlier was that I I
did say there are four bubbles right the
characters of a CTO and you'll find that
a lot of these things overlap so it's
not like they're completely different to
each other so you'll find a lot of
overlap and the operating model is and
you look at the first three things over
here you talk about people process and
tools and technology and you see they
say there's a bit of overlap and yes
there is a bit of an overlap but this is
slightly different right so when you
take up a new role with a CTO or
anything else and you have a an
organizational unit to run you want to
figure out what is the operating model
that works for you what is the word you
know when I just spoke about people
leadership skill right this is more
around the roles and responsibilities
that you want to set within your
organizational unit what's what's going
to how are we going to organize your
your entire team is gonna put it put in
like a matrix truck sure you're gonna
have like dev managers and QA managers
and head of architecture and things like
that
or you know you you know like the matrix
or the Spotify model and all those kind
of things
you need to figure out what is what is
best for you how many things is there's
no one-size-fits-all right and it
depends on the size of your organization
and what your organization does and your
structure could be quite different so
you need to kind of like go and figure
it out yourself
same thing with things like processing
tools right I mean you can say well my
provide know what my process it's scrum
right it doesn't quite work that way the
sizes of like at ADL at one point in
time we had over 44 scrum teams right
you can actually think about having 44
scrum teams and delivering a large
program of work you know it's not easy
if you basically say well guys go ahead
and use scrum and come back to me later
right so you gotta have some kind of a
process that actually brings it all
together and working that out beforehand
is gonna be really really useful again
governance is another one that you want
to think about you know particularly
when the organization starts to get
bigger and bigger how are you gonna
handle you know budgeting you know if
you've got a really good you know
feature or you want to introduce some
things you know where's the budget for
this coming from so you want to have a
way in which you start to approve
there's got to be some kind of
governance that governs things like this
what about architecture right in a
really small you know you talk about
things like oh I'm gonna empower the
teams we're gonna let them do their
stuff and you know that's really quick
sounds really good on paper but in large
enterprise when each and every team goes
and does things on their own and they
starts buying all these products and
they doing the same thing in different
ways at some point then somebody's going
to look like holy you know we
bought all these tools that do exactly
the same thing why could why didn't we
consolidate right so what are you gonna
have you want to have things like design
authorities or whatever that actually
brings in together or some level of
governance to make sure that these
things don't happen so setting all these
things is going to be important same
thing with culture and measures and
motivators right culture is a really
important thing and as a CEO you have a
really big role to play in my opinion I
actually once I worked for a company and
when I when I gotten over there the
culture of the company you know
there's nothing wrong with there I mean
the way that actually worked was that
every developer had an actual
workstation and where they actually sat
and that's what they actually would go
to the workstation the logic behind that
was hey you know what the workstation is
really good it's it's cheap and you can
actually get a really powerful desktop
and you know put it in there and that's
how they work and now I came in and I
was like you know I put what about the
mobility of these people what if they
actually wanted to work from home so the
way we actually build the company was we
we set things up so yeah you know making
it really hard for people to actually
work from home as an example and for me
to actually basically go in and say well
from now onwards we're not gonna buy any
of these things everybody gets a laptop
it's a big change in mindset for a lot
of people I had and I basically said you
know I I'm happy for people who work
from home we're gonna change the way
people work you know as long as your
team knows we're gonna measure people on
what they contributed rather than the
amount of time that I actually spent at
work it's a hard thing for a lot of
people to actually grasp I had one
person who actually came up to me and
said oh you know my son is actually I
actually saw that what the managers
actually came up to me and and she said
oh this person had come to her and said
her son had broken her his arm and so
you know wanted to be at home at 3:30 or
something like that when the school
finishes and so she wanted to come and
come in at like 6:30 a.m. start work at
6:30 a.m. and go leave for home you know
leave home early or something left and I
and she said like I I just wanted to you
know I've told her she can do that but I
just want to check with you and I said
like the first thing is like it's like
the answer is no because there are other
ways to solve this problem she can
actually work from home why does she
have to come in because you know she
lived from quite far away she would have
to catch a train at like 5:30 a.m. or
something like that and you know I have
concerns about her safety as well coming
in so early in the morning to city and I
said you need to talk about this thing
change the way you think it's easy it's
you know it's okay for her to work from
home and she wants to come a little bit
late I'm happy with it if she wants to
work from home for the next three weeks
until her son gets better I'm happy with
that and
and a lot of these things actually
changes the culture the mindset of the
people itself right so anyway so the
same thing with casual clothes you know
this is this place actually had very
formal clothes and for me too and a lot
of other gyms thought that looking
professional or professionalism and had
an impact on their productivity so they
thought that if they look really smart
and they would actually contribute more
and you know like I had a battle to
fight to actually change that mindset as
well a lot of these things contribute to
the culture of the of your
organizational unit and all that and a
CTO I think has a really important role
to play in all of these things now once
you've got your operating model down pat
the next thing you need to focus on is
you know what is called the operating
rhythm this is like who do you you know
how free you know who do you catch up
with about what and when and how
frequently now you could have a team
where you know you've got your immediate
reports you may have to have you may
want to have one-on-one with these
people right like how frequently do it
do it do it do you want to do it once a
week or maybe once every two weeks
there's no right or wrong answer I
didn't they you know you're it depends
on your or your style and and their
style your team style and everything
else you may want to when do you have
team meetings do you have once a week do
you have once every two weeks what about
an all-inclusive Town Hall of all your
immediate reports and this is something
that you want to have do you want to
have it once every quarter once every
six months like I said there's no right
or wrong answer but if you can I feel
worked it out and people know this is
the operating rhythm by which you
actually operate it makes it so much
easier for everyone and the operating
rhythm is also very very important way
for stakeholder management so not only
do you need to manage people above you
you know your boss and you know if
you're a CEO you know your CEO and the
board maybe you may you will also want
to make sure that your peers other GM
certain organization and so on you know
that you kind of like manage their
expectations and you need to manage the
expectations of other peoples in the
organization as well
so going back to my favorite two-by-two
matrix
you know if I kind of like start to map
out influence these people have on one
hand and the impact that they have we
start to map different people on where
they actually sit in the chain you you
can actually get an idea on whether you
you know how you manage them you whether
you need to collaborate with these
people because they are they have their
very high influence and also have a high
impact on on the product and everything
else or you know you just monitor the
monitor you know make sure you are you
know you keep them informed so you can
actually use this matrix to actually
determine the level of communication
that's needed with certain groups of
people or certain individuals and so on
alright now that we've kind of like we
come to the last bubble right this is
the this is the strategic thinking piece
and so thinking you know I've got a
whole bunch of patterns that I want to
talk about over here and these are
literally tools that you can actually
have in your toolkit that you bring up
that'll help you in your own thinking
when you want to think about how you
want to move your product or your
company or your project forward
strategically some of these things
you've probably heard of the first one I
want to talk about is what how many
people have heard of SWOT analysis right
it's probably the probably the most
popular one that people use all the time
and so what stands for strengths
weaknesses opportunities and threats
again you see my favorite 2x2 matrix
oh yeah now it's trends is all about
let's say you have an internal product
stenz come from within the product is
the origin of it is within the internal
and this is it's quite helpful so if you
look at your start to map out the
strength of your product may say hey you
know what our features are you know our
user interface is really really good
awesome and everybody likes it you can
start to list some of the features that
are real strengths of the product itself
and and then the weaknesses are again
internal origin but these things are
harmful
and you can say well everything is
really good about my product you never
really likes it but if you actually
start to scale it beyond hundred
thousand people it's gonna start to fall
apart that's a big weakness right and
you need to call this out have you guys
also another weakness could be things
like you know you wanna kinda like start
to sell this product overseas
however our product is not even
internationalized or you know we don't
have any internationals in localization
in it so that's going to be a big that's
a big problem for the product itself
threats are again harmful but the source
of the origin of this is external think
of it like you know you're selling
online things you know you've got an
online store you gotta start thinking
well hey Amazon is now it's already here
you know in Australia so how does things
like when these companies come over how
is it going to affect affect the product
affect the business
what about legislative changes if we
have some legislative changes that are
happening is that gonna affect our
product how what kind of impact it
actually has opportunities on the other
hand are again things that you can able
to leverage on these are again these are
external in origin but they're gonna be
really helpful things like you know I
had a friend in a start-up in India and
they introduced GST in India right they
were building an accounting application
and they saw this as an opportunity
right they actually built all of these
things in the right time and it really
took off
I think my OB probably did the same
thing when Jesus lives in trees in
Australia right so you know you start to
think about what are the external
factors that can be favorable to you
what's going to be helpful now if you
actually start to put all these things
together that will help you in
determining where you want to focus your
efforts and so on it'll gonna help with
your strategic thinking now PESTEL is
another list that you can actually
prepare and this is kind of like a next
thing you know we talked about SWAT in
terms of strengths weaknesses and
threats and so on pestle again it stands
for political economic social
technological and one mental and legal
so you kind of like start to look at
your product itself and say hey from a
political point of view how are what are
the things that are that will actually
affect our the the direction of the
company the direction of the product
everything else things like you change
in common if the change in government is
gonna affect me I mean you think about
AGL as an energy company and we take a
lot of flack from the government what
happens when the government changes you
know is it gonna be better are we gonna
be better off are we gonna be voice off
and I'm sure my bosses are probably
thinking about those things right what
about things like political instability
and political you know foreign trade
policies a lot of these things are all
political and they could have an impact
on your product and so on economic is a
good one what happens when the interest
rate goes up or goes down what about
exchange rate I used to do consulting
for a company in Melbourne and they did
a lot of selling overseas and with the
dollar drop then the Aussie dollar
dropped you know their revenues went up
dramatically because the Aussie job at
that point in time actually dropped a
fair bit right because they're selling
in US Dollars and they're making making
more money when it got converted Aussie
dollars now the reverse also holds true
right so if let's say you're importing
and like some kind of IOT device from
from China and your dollar drops and now
you're paying more for it and that has
an impact on you know the profit that
you actually make and all that kind of
stuff so so unique ah you need to kind
of like decide on what you know the
economic factors how how favorable they
are going to be for your product and you
need to kind of like strategies on that
another one is social right what about
the demographics demographics of the
population we know what kind of
demography you want to target with your
product and you know what about the
cultural sensitivities let's say you're
going to sell your product in Asia or
you know India and so on is there
anything that's actually gonna stop you
from selling it because of the culture
of that country and everything else
technological emerging technology I
already mentioned blockchain several
times I can't resist doing it one more
time so you know what what is some of
these emerging technologies have right
the maturity of this technology if you
want to start using them what if these
technologies actually fail miserably
gonna have an impact on your company and
so those are the kind of things that
you'll start to think about
environmental you know I touched briefly
about AGL and you know if we are in the
process of actually generating
electricity by burning coal and that
contributes to you know pollution and
things like that what is the business
strategy that we want to look for in the
future right so those are the kind of
things that that that will be helpful me
if the company wants to shut down you
know all the all these these mines that
cause a lot of pollution what are the
other things from technology point of
view what are the things that you can
actually help help with that consumer
laws and regulatory requirements it's
another area right the loss actually
change and you need to keep in touch
with that and particularly when you want
to move things to know other countries I
had a former colleague of mine who went
and worked for a company that wrote
bedding software right everything was
fine here in the US I think they started
using containers and so on and so forth
where they you know that's where all the
application was deployed and they took
it to the to the US and they ran into
problems because to me to run these
these applications in the US they they
have some kind of software that they run
that will you know that will check
whether to you know they will run these
softwares and that will basically say
whether it's okay or not and they
couldn't run it on containers guess what
they had to do they have kind of like
redo their applications real quick and
make sure that it's compliant with their
tests and things like that so if you
have a really good understanding of a
lot of these things beforehand you will
you know not run into problems later on
and stuff good strategies is another way
of of you know finding out where your
product can actually be and if you if
you kind of like marker what the
strategy of the company is and you start
to look at things like you know if for
example you want to be in the existing
market with the existing product you
know what are the things that you need
to do I mean like let me let me explain
this with an example right and I'll use
agile as an example it's probably easier
for people to understand
so if the company strategy is that we
want to stay in the existing market and
we don't want to device where we
diversify we don't want to add new
products then it's fine that's the
company strategy right so what you may
want to do is the only way to to grow is
to through market penetration so you may
want to start in with more on things
like marketing and sales and so on and
so forth right but if we basically
decide to introduce new products within
the same market so for example in angel
they say oh you're gonna start to sell
broadband and mobile phones you want to
get into telecom market a long selling
along with energy we want to do that
then then you know you need to make sure
that the that's the company strategy
then you need to make sure the
technology will start to support some of
these things
what if agent 1 is start selling the
product in Singapore right so they got
the existing product is like basically
selling energy and electricity and gas
and they want to start selling it in
Singapore or somewhere in Asia you need
to start thinking from a technological
point of view hey how am I going to
support these things I'm going to start
making sure that my application is now
internationalized and you know supports
localizing all those kind of things so
what about diversification what if Asia
basically decides today you know we want
to start making solar panels on cells in
the US it's a completely different
business right so anyway so there's an
soft growth strategy will kind of like
help you figure out where you need to
focus on as well based on the company
strategy overall sir I see another one
is this thing called BCG growth-share
matrix B C stands for Boston Consulting
Group and you know for a long time they
you know they they talk about you know
if you have if you have various products
within the market and they like again my
favorite two-by-two matrix where you
start to put the market share on one
axis and then you start to put your
market growth on the other and see where
your product release it's in all right
and for products that have a very low
growth and have very low market share
they call them dogs right and the cash
cows are the ones where the MA you have
a really high market share but that
market isn't going to grow your stars
are the ones where you know you have a
really high market share and the market
is gonna grow even more right
you know the area where your product
really should be but once you actually
put all your products and these things
right then you put them as bubbles then
you can start to look at like hey hang
on a second right do I need to move my
product from being a dog into like a you
know or you know if it's a it's a cash
cow right now do I need to move it into
some other you know quadrant or whatever
it is right so you can I start start to
see various investments can actually go
now keep in mind that you know Mac shell
doesn't necessarily mean how much profit
you're making or say you could you could
still be having a really little market
share and you know market growth is also
really poor but if you're making it you
know a lot of money on it then you may
want to continue investing on it right
and similarly you may want to start to
milk your cash cow as much as you as you
want to before you move out of that so
but anyway said this is another thing
that will actually help you come up with
the right strategies and things like
that another now one of the things I
want to talk about right so we talked
about all these statuses and so on and
so forth now there are there are
companies out there like McKenzie and
Boston Consulting Group and so on what
they do is they specialize in helping
companies come up with you know if would
stategy and so on so a lot of things
that actually talk about right these
patterns and so on is they they have
this in their toolkits they basically
bring them out depending on the company
and so on and then say hey you know have
you considered this and you know this is
the the Porter's five forces model and
let's see how that actually works right
so Porter's five forces another
interesting one where it kind of like
lets you analyze you know where you we
analyze you know the forces that are
actually acting that'll have an impact
on on your company and your product and
everything else so there's always this
threat of new entrants right so you
always have this existing competitor I
see you have a bunch of competitors and
you have an existing rivalry that that
currently exists but what happens with
the threat of new entrants think of you
know Amazon you know like I gave this
example of you've got an online store
and Amazon is coming into Australia you
know you have new entrants coming in
that could have a massive impact
on your company the product that you've
got and everything else so you need to
start thinking about now the if the the
the barrier of entry is quite high the
cost of actually getting to the industry
is quite high that's a good thing for
you right and if we are thinking of
selling things like broadband maybe the
barrier of entry now is much lower then
you may start to think about hey you
know for other people to enter the
market is actually not a big deal you
may want to status it and whether you
want to enter or not right so those are
the kind of things that you think about
take up substitutes what if people don't
want to use your product you know the
kind of frog that you use I mean the
very good examples blockbusters and
Netflix right so you had your bricks and
mortar store where you'd go in and rent
DVDs and so on
completely Netflix change the way that
works they've they've gone into another
way of consuming the same content and
they do it online now and that they
completely put blockbuster out of
business and you start thinking about
things like cell phones and landlines
right so I mean landlines in people
don't want to use landlines anymore
because there's another alternative for
them so what happens is the threat of
subsidy something else comes in that
completely replaces that that kind of
technology job buyer bargaining power
you know do the buyer have a lot of
bargaining power that dictates how you
operate if I have the power to actually
switch let's say any energy is another
good example if I can actually switch
over to someone else with ease so the
buyer has a lot more bargaining power
and we need to make sure that we keep
the customer happy the same thing with
supplier bargaining power if we are now
dependent on certain suppliers and if
they have complete control over you know
your product roadmap and things like
that you know that's probably not a not
a good thing so you kind of like put all
these things together to try and figure
out what the SATA see moving forward is
now the last thing I want to talk about
is about roadmaps and I just realized
that I had the numbering on these things
wrong but it says okay so this is you
know for one of the things you know it's
the things that I've been talking about
primarily in things in terms of strategy
and things like that it's focused on
some of the smaller companies where
you're building
car locks and so on when you start to
think about large enterprises and so on
you know there are other things that you
need to do in terms of strategizing in
roadmap and so on one of the things that
we do in large companies is we kind of
like first we figure out what the
business capability model is which is
effectively we say you know this is what
the business actually does you know we
say we are retail we are in the retail
business we need to do a bunch of things
we need to make sure that we as we are
selling things inventory management is a
really important thing right customer
[Music]
you know we need like a things like CRM
and things like customer management and
holding on to the records is an
important thing so each and everything
you kind of like end up mapping that
into a business capability once you've
done that into business capability the
second thing that you do is you look at
the maturity of that itself so is the
business mature enough so these are the
cable these are business needs but where
is the maturity and then some of these
things like you know what this is this
is a business that actually is real
highly reliant on on customer base and
looking at it but guess what we are
storing all our customers in a
spreadsheet all right so it's not very
mature so that could be a that could be
a red box in that right so once you kind
of like identified that that will help
you define where are the investment that
needs to to go in that could actually
drive the investments that are going in
and you know you can actually start to
work out things like your current set
architecture that'll help the current
set architecture is basically your the
current business capability model and
that's what it actually supports but if
you want to if you if you gottem if
you've built up the maturity model and
you've got a future state and where the
business needs to go then you could
start to build your future state
architecture as well and that can drive
things like your roadmaps to address the
gaps so you know this is where your
maturity is maturities but this is where
you want to get to I need to invest in
these technologies and I need to invest
in these products to actually get from
from here to there so those are the
things that you can actually quickly map
out so the last bit in terms of of you
know cities thinking is this you know
mindset right one of the things that
Asia has done really well is they've
promoted a lot of things like design
thinking and human centered design
thinking people so we've run a lot of
training for people to kind of like get
that way of thinking and that's kind of
like help in coming up with doing more
innovation literally and of course you
know we do run hackathons as well so a
lot of companies do run hackathons they
they do it again they've got an
operating rhythm right so they run it
like maybe once every six months and so
on and hackathons also help in promoting
innovation within the organization there
was one company that I you know that I
used to consult for and they started
running hackathon and and the CTO of the
company actually told me that since they
started running hackathons there are
some really good ideas that came out of
it that they had to drop some of the
existing planned features because these
ideas were so much better than that and
so they were starting to drive value for
these customers based on that so that's
really good thing right
so we also do when you know you scaled
agile framework at azl so as far as
every quarter we do have an innovation
sprint where the the devs or the team I
should say can can do something
in a way - right that's another way of
actually promoting an innovation mindset
yeah so yeah every quarter that's right
every P I every P I the last sprint the
last sprint is difficult like I think
that's what scale is safe recommends as
well right but a lot of few times that
is used to play catch-up so these are
some of the books that I actually
recommend some of the content that I
actually spoke about today if you want
to kind of like dig in a little bit
deeper these books can will help you I
will actually tweet these slides so you
know you don't have to look at you know
you know happy for you to take photos
and and tweet it again and so on but I
will I will publish them so you don't
have to write them down or take pictures
basically I want to finish up with this
with this this tip right I'm not sure if
you have any of you read this book
called outliers right a couple of hands
going up call out lies by Malcolm
Gladwell one of the things he actually
talks about and you've probably heard
this theory is that to become an expert
at something you need to spend about
10,000 hours so if you're you know if
you want to a good violin player and
you're playing in concerts and things
like that you probably did about 10,000
hours of practice to get to where you
are yeah they talked about a whole bunch
of other things right but I think that
the gist of that is like that's one of
the things that you talked about right
now there are a lot of other people
actually said well that's not entirely
true and you know there's this thing
called deliberate practice and to look
it up if you if you can and deliberate
practice is all about basically
identifying a specific activity and you
kind of like repeated with with feedback
loops so you kind of like try and learn
this and then say hey how will have
actually done this thing and you take
the the feedback from there and you kind
of like try to improve again you can't
like keep pushing the limits on this and
the theory is that with deliberate if
engaging in deliberate practice will
actually get you to be an expert at
something a lot quicker all right so
what I'm trying to say is that you know
I spoke about a lot of skills that you
can actually pick up on your way to
becoming a CTO one day and you know with
a lot of deliberate practice some of
these things don't have to be like a
lifelong experience to actually pick up
those skills as well so with that
message I think I just like just ran
over the one hour as well I want to call
it a wrap I'm happy to take questions
but thank you
and make sure you put in your feedback
at the end of the session as well and
green is the color